be the person who takes initiative it
can take a lot of energy but I'm that
person in my friendship groups one of
them is I do a Sunday dinner so every
Sunday when I'm in town I say to anyone
who lives in Sydney who I know come for
dinner just bring a bottle of wine bring
dessert bring something and have a fee
and just let me know like four hours in
advance if you're coming along bring
Partners bring anyone and that Sunday
dinner is a glue for some of my
relationships and not to say that like
those people are only coming for the
free food but they're so busy that
having a discreet day where I know that
we're going to see each other actually
is a lot easier for a lot of people to
navigate